Bonjour, et bienvenue à tous dans cette FAQ Golden Moustache.
Bienvenue dans le podcast de FloBer.
A quel personnage que vous avez joué, vous identifiez-vous le plus ?
Plus jamais ça !
C'est le mien !
Putain !
J'ai oublié de l'éteindre !
A quel personnage que vous avez joué, vous identifiez-vous le plus ?
c'est dur à dire !
Surtout que c'est pas écrit !
Brice de Nice ! Avant tout.
Bah non mais les personnages de "Badass", en vrai !
Bah.... Pas du tout !
Plutôt ceux de "Il a mis son sexe" puisque c'est vraiment nous !
Bah c'est nous en fait !
C'est juste la vérité.
C'est un docu, finalement cette vidéo !
Ouais.
C'est un doc.
Un doc animalier.
Un docu.
Une prise de vue.
Une vidéo.
Ma mère me manque.
Je pense que je m'identifie le plus à Spiderman !
Parce que... Bah... Déjà j'étais très content de jouer ! C'était un rêve d'enfant !
Un grand pouvoir, implique...
De niquer sa race.
Vous ça va ?
Je vais dire Jojo.
J'ai un compte Linkedin
Oh non non non, Je ne touche pas à ça moi.
Mais sinon un petit selfie !
Ah ouais ! Ouais un selfie c'est bien ça va me faire du bien ça !
Je dirais Jésus, dans "L'Assemblée Intergalactique" !
Ce n'est pas du tout que je m'identifie à Jésus, même si je suis le fils de Dieu, mais ça, ça n'a rien à voir !
Comment je pouvais savoir qu'il ne marchait pas sur l'eau, moi ?
A quand une nouvelle chanson qui va me rester en tête ?
Ben tout de suite ! Trois, quatre ! Attends je vais prendre une guitare
Je peux avoir une guitare s'il vous plaît ?
Est-ce qu'on peut me jeter une guitare ?
Trois, quatre !
FloBer est-ce que c'est ton vrai nom ou est-ce que c'est un pseudonyme ? Et pourquoi ce B en majuscule ?
Et bien parce que je m'appelle Florent Bernard. Et que du coup Flo de Florent, Ber de Bernard,
et vu qu'à mon nom, il y a une majuscule au début, comme tous les noms de famille de la Terre, ben je l'ai gardé.
Est-ce qu'il y aura une suite de Jojo à Golden Moustache ?
Non. Il n'y aura pas de suite à Jojo.
Je pense qu'il y aura une suite à ma vie, ce qui est déjà pas mal...
Ça me fait du bien de vous parler !
Ça ne te pose pas de soucis de supporter les mecs de Golden Moustache qui sont très nombreux ?
Ben non en soit ce n'est pas un souci mais juste des fois bah tu vois,
entre deux réunions, je fais une petite sieste et euh..
Bah y a une bite sur mon épaule qui vient de poser et ça me fait peur car je ne m'y attendais pas.
Est-ce que vous allez faire d'autres "Parisiens ou Marseillais ont-il un coeur"?
Oui !
On aimerait bien faire.
On a fait ! Qui va être diffusé.
Putain !
Oh ça à vraiment craqué !
Quelles qualités faut-il pour travailler dans un collectif comme celui-ci ? Euh...
Bah je dirais des... des seins.
Il faut être volontaire !
Des gros seins.
Genre être sans cesse en train de proposer des idées mais s'ils vous disent "oh la la mais elle est nulle à chier cette idée" faut la proposer quand même"!
Des gros beaux seins.
Parce que d'une idée nulle, un autre auteur peut rebondir dessus et vous dire... et vous en faire une idée bien.
Plutôt laiteux.
Essayer de mettre son ego à l'entrée de la porte de la réunion d'auteurs.
Faut un peu admirer aussi les gens avec qui on bosse en fait, faut les trouver d'un point de vu extérieur intéressants artistiquement.
Mais essayer de ne pas prendre personnellement si une idée ce n'est pas prise, etc...
Il ne faut pas avoir peur, justement, des critiques.
Qui, d'entre vous, est célibataire, et qui, d'entre vous, est en couple ?
Je sors depuis maintenant... ça va faire 6 mois ! Non, 7 mois d'ailleurs même.
Et je suis très heureux parce que je sors avec Franck Dubosc !
Je l'ai rencontré sur le tournage de Disco, et depuis bah c'est le grand amour quoi !
C'est pas vrai ma meuf est tellement mieux que Franck Dubosc...
Quelle a été votre parcours avant d'entrer chez Golden Moustache ?
J'ai fait un BTS audiovisuel en option exploitation.
J'ai fait une école de ciné, assez chère, sur trois ans.
Et ensuite, j'ai fait un conservatoire de théâtre dans le 5ème arrondissement de Paris.
Après j'ai fondé ma boîte avec toi.
Ouais !
C'était bien, on à filmé des clips de métal, et on à filmé Shy'm,
ce qui nous a donc appris tout !
Pendant ce temps-là je faisais des vidéos, je jouais dedans et j'en réalisais certaines autres.
J'ai décidé de créer ma propre web-série qui s'appelle  "Le journal de Lolo", et grâce à ça, j'ai été repérée par François Descraques !
J'ai tout de suite fait beaucoup de courts métrages.
J'ai fait une fac de cinéma.
J'ai rencontré Slimane Baptiste Berhoun.
Après j'ai travaillé en tant que monteur et en parallèle j'écrivais avec Julien Josselin de Suricate.
Ensuite j'ai fait "Visiteur du futur ", j'ai rencontré FloBer, et je suis arrivé à Golden Moustache.
Quels sketchs avez-vous préféré tourner ?
"Le pet", c'est un sketch LAB que j'ai fait l'année dernière avec Carlito et Nicolas Berno,
et ça parle d'une fille qui doit vivre avec son pet qui est Nicolas Berno !
Ça fait longtemps qu'on ne s'est pas vus.
Ça te fait toujours autant rire !
Quelle est la vidéo que tu as préféré réaliser ? Alors je pense que c'est le "Bureau des rêves", parce qu'il y avait plein de comédiens fous.
Il y avait beaucoup de place pour l'improvisation, et parce que le thème m'était propre et cher, et qu'en plus les gens l'ont bien apprécié donc voilà.
Son taff le soûle ! il a pas de meuf, il a pas d'amis.
Pas de petit chat.
Quoi ?
De petit chat.
Oui d'accord, enfin c'est quoi le rapport ?
C'est hyper réconfortant, un petit chat.
Comme un ami avec des poils.
Pourquoi "Golden Moustache" ?
Alors moi je sais pas, mais Valentin Vincent sait.
Je suis le seul à avoir la réponse ! Et je vais la donner en exclusivité aujourd'hui.
Alors, pourquoi le nom de Golden Moustache, en fait c'est très simple, c'est juste que...
T'as vu le...?
As-tu des conseils pour un comédien qui débute ?
Faut juste savoir si tu penses à ça tous les jours,
Si à chaque fois que tu te lèves,
A chaque fois que tu prends ton café,
A chaque fois que tu marches, tu penses à ça.
Quelle est la personne la plus relou de l'équipe ?
Ben sans hésiter je dirais que c'est Adrien Ménielle, parce qu'il a un genre de tic, un peu agaçant.
J'adore les fleurs !
Qui vous aimez bien sur youtube ?
J'aime bien Antoine Daniel.
J'aime beaucoup les chroniques de Karim Debach ! Je suis très content qu'il ait recommencé ses chroniques parce que c'est vraiment très bien.
J'aime beaucoup aussi un mec qui s'appelle Nota Bene, qui fait des vidéos très intéressantes.
Est-il prévu de faire un film avec toute la team Golden Moustache ?
Ce n'est pas prévu aujourd'hui de faire un film avec toute la team de Golden Moustache mais ça serait super cool !
Oui ! Et d'ailleurs on a un pitch ! Guitare !
Il s'agit de trois hommes, et d'un couffin, c'est un scénario inédit !
Je pense qu'il s'agit... Ah merde, c'est déjà fait.
Sinon je crois, que Raphaël Carlier a décidé de réaliser le remake de Disco, avec toute la team de Golden Moustache.
Raphaël Descraques jouera Franck Dubosc,
Bon, Aude Gogny-Goubert évidemment dans le rôle d'Emmanuelle Béart, Gérard Depardieu, McFly...
Aimerais-tu swapper dans le corps d'une femme pour de bon ?
J'aimerais beaucoup swapper dans le corps d'une femme, non pas pour les raisons lubriques qu'on puisse se dire, mais aussi pour surtout apprendre à les comprendre !
Parce qu'elles ont des choses différentes, il arrive des choses différentes à leur corps, elles ont des propriétés différentes.
Et... Carrément !
Découvrir l'orgasme féminin, découvrir aussi ce que c'est que d'avoir des règles,
d'enfanter peut être aussi, ça peut carrément être, je ne dis pas forcément cool, mais super intéressant pour essayer de se comprendre entre êtres humains !
Voilà.
Quelles sont tes sources d'inspiration dans l'écriture qui est très travaillée ?
Merci beaucoup.
Alors des inspirations j'en ai plein !
Kevin Smith ! En termes de dialogues, de personnages, de mélange c'est marrant et en même temps, c'est un peu touchant, c'est incroyable.
Judd Apatow ! Edgar Wright !
Et après il y a pleins d'autres films chanmés qui m'ont grave influencé.
Et non ! Ça non ! Beaucoup moins en fait ! Pas du tout, je vais le remettre ici.
Et bien je vous le donne en mille ! La FAQ est terminée !
Dans cette vidéo vous avez peut être vus des tee-shirts Golden Moustache !
Des mugs Golden Moustache qui appartiennent finalement à Golden Moustache qui représentent des sketchs de Golden Moustache.
Et bien vous pouvez les retrouver sur le Store, de Golden Moustache.
Eh ! Salut les zigotos !
Bisous à tous également !
Et bien nous on est super contents de vous avoir avec nous au quotidien !
Continuez de nous suivre ! Je vous fais plein de gros bisous ! Et à très bientôt !
Eh ! Je suis à New York !
Eh Taxi !